[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
yes
what is up everybody we're doing it it's
the first stream of the year the very
first stream of the year
and i gotta say usually
i'm pretty stressed out in these
mornings before i stream and this
morning was the chillest morning
of
it's been a long time since it's been
this chill before stream so i'm i'm
excited
it's good to have you all here we got if
you listen carefully
what's that sound
we got we got some music popping off
sodamonte crushing it um really helping
me make these streams as good as they
can be
so we're working on them we're making
them good for y'all welcome back thank
you for joining me we're gonna do some
cool stuff
um now if you don't know what we're
doing
then i should probably tell you
so right now i'm running this challenge
it's called the infinite journeys 3d
community challenge where i'm
challenging all of you all
3d artists who are passionate out there
who want to just create and level up
uh with a little prompt i got a prompt
for you you can download it if you
haven't started yet um
you can just you know in the description
you'll see all the stuff for getting
started it'll take you to the discord
page where you'll get the download link
and everything for all the project files
now what i'm challenging y'all to do is
create the coolest render montage of all
time so each of each one of y'all are
going to take a little tiny five second
piece
of some sort of travel montage you're
going to put your character in you're
going to put a character at least one um
in a mode of transportation of some sort
and i'm gonna piece them all together
and you know how this stuff this stuff
works we're gonna put together the
sickest travel montage ever in march and
then we got a top 100 montage as well
we're giving out prizes we got sponsors
we got
max on camp mograph wacom rococo
uh the looking glass and mograph.com you
guys are gonna win a whole bunch of cool
stuff
um the prizes are nuts prizes are
absolutely insane if you don't know if
you know what i'm talking about go watch
the announcement video it's the video i
posted right before this
and uh come right on back and get
excited because we're gonna be working
on our submissions together i'm gonna
start my submission with y'all guys
right here and we got d vaughn williams
in the house it's a brand new stream sun
what up devon
god dang davon we go back all the way
back to high school
he's coming out soon it's gonna be
exciting um
what else are we doing so the stream
what else are we doing on the stream so
basically here's what's gonna happen
um
y'all are working on your submissions
for infinite uh infinite journeys
i'm gonna show you some of those
submissions show you what i like what i
think y'all are doing a good job with um
we'll do that somewhere in in the middle
of this stream but i'm just gonna get
right to work i'm gonna take my 2d
concept that i put together in photoshop
i'm going to show you how i did that i'm
going to show you how i came up with my
idea why i'm choosing the idea that i'm
choosing and then i'm going to take that
and make a 3d block out in cinema 4d
i've already started it i'm just going
to perfect it so by the end of the
stream the goal is to have a nice
3d block out of my 2d concept so that's
what we're doing we're taking it step by
step
and then yeah we're going to do some uh
weekly challenge winners at the end of
this stream because we do weekly
challenges on the discord as well but
you know what y'all i have rambled for
far enough
so let's switch it over
to
the sponsor of today's stream the first
sponsor of the infinite journey stream
back in a minute don't move your butts
we'll see in a second now i know you all
know the answer to this one what's the
one thing that all of us 3d artists
can't create without
computers you know we use them every
single day and rely on them to create
our 3d art except for maybe that one
dynamic machines artist who rendered
their submission on their phone how you
did that i will never know but i do know
micro center is the first official
sponsor of the infinite journeys live
streams if you're looking for an
affordable workstation computer parts
electronics networking tools tvs laptops
monitors you name it micro center has
got you covered and i know that pc part
prices have been off the charts for a
while but micro center is running deals
all the time so if you're looking for
parts at the lowest price click that
link in the description to see what you
can find and if you're an artist who
needs an affordable workstation micro
center has knowledgeable staff over the
phone and in store who can help you find
the best rig for your budget and if
you're like me and miss the good old
days of going into the store and
actually holding the item in your hand
that you're gonna buy to see if it works
or not then book those plane tickets
because micro center is giving anybody
anybody who walks in off the street and
into one of their stores a free 240
gigabyte solid state drive so the next
time you're in a pinch and need computer
parts
lots of computer parts then micro center
has got the best deals click that link
in the description to get the deals to
get the free 240 gigabyte ssd and load
up on your computer parts for your very
next render
good times very good times shout outs to
microcenter thank you for sponsoring
this one
really appreciate it good times it's
good times at micro center it's like the
last place you can actually walk into
and pick up some parts fries they went
out of business they couldn't hang on
they didn't do it
biker center still standing up so
appreciate y'all
um
what are we doing now let's hop into it
so i'm gonna
switch on over
and
i'm gonna give a little little shout
outs to people here before we jump in
all right so we got visual in the house
what up visual
uh one of our moderators holding it down
on the discord server of course
sodamonte behind the scenes right now
helping me with the stream
uh i saw my buddy d von williams one of
my very best friends up in here who else
do we got
any familiar faces
what's up everybody
4k productions
good to see you how you doing
we got blender users we got c4d users we
got unreal engine users we got everybody
in the house it doesn't matter what
program you're using
all that matters is what you're creating
and that you're having a good time doing
it so
that's exciting very exciting what's up
phillip
noah
it's going down
yo slate we got slate in the house
what's up slate
render warrior good to see you again
it's been a minute thanks for making it
back that's awesome heck yeah
damn we got everybody up in the house
what's going on
it's really good to see you all back
here i'm just really excited about like
all the stuff that we've been doing and
setting up for in january obviously you
know that i hadn't streamed at all in
january because i'm trying to make the
best foundation
um for myself for this channel for the
discord before we just hop into it
blindly right
um so we have some really exciting stuff
for the discord plan even after this
challenge
um
and
yeah i can't wait i can't wait to get
into it it's gonna be some cool stuff i
can't really announce anything yet um
but just know that right after this
challenge we're gonna have some cool
stuff popping off on the discord and if
you don't know what i'm talking about
the discord server it's a place for you
know artists like yourself to get
together and just have a sense of
community and get people to
help you out you know you can answer
questions you can ask questions
it's a good time it's a good place to
learn and grow together that's the whole
point
bobby shout outs man thank you so much
thanks for the super chat what will the
trends transition be on the challenge
and do we add it into our renders there
is no transition
there is no transition at all
uh it's just a cut a simple cut and it's
gonna be a match cut
now if you all don't know what a match
cut is
let me let me show you really quick
so basically
a match cut is like when
when you go okay so if you all have seen
2001 a space odyssey is basically when
uh the monkey throws the bone up into
the air and then the camera's on the
bone and then the bone
it cuts to the spaceship that is in the
shape of that bone
that's a match cut so it's like
two
two images that have like similar visual
weight
and that's what we're doing in this
challenge um let me pull up the
so this is my block out this is what
i've created so far
and
um
let me open up the base file for you so
you guys can get an idea
of what we're looking at here
um
i think this is it yep here we go so
this is the base project file you'll be
getting if you hit play it's 120 frames
5 seconds long 24 fps
[Music]
um
and you got a window you can put some
characters
um here in these seats
kind of looks like a train but
it's supposed to be open to any vehicle
it could be a car it could be a
motorcycle could be a spaceship it could
be
in my case uh
i don't know i'm trying to go between
like a
a speeder looking thing i don't know if
this dude is trying to set the ground
speed record
or if they're in an airplane but we'll
get into that in a minute but
what's uh
the connecting
points between all of these submissions
is this window so you need to keep this
window relatively the same size now
obviously depending on the shape of your
scene like in the shape of your vehicle
that window will change but you can see
here i have the majority
of that
that chunk still available right so
that's the original
window that you're looking at and then
obviously you can see how my window
basically fits in that your window is
gonna change that's okay
just know that it needs to be the
central large focal point of
your submission and you gotta throw a
character in there get your character in
there somewhere it's gonna be cool so
i'm very excited we're gonna like we we
nearly have what
3 800 what's the last i checked how many
people do we have
in this challenge right now
we have 3 800
people who are working on some renders
so that's that's pretty sweet
that is pretty sweet so bobby long
answered your question it's going to be
a simple cut and we're going to use the
match cut technique
to blend all these renders together very
much like we did in alternate realities
or parallel dimensions
and who else do we got we got another
super chat popping off tret
appreciate you it's not a bribe you know
i didn't take it as such but now that
you mention it i don't you know you
didn't have you didn't have to
to mention the bribe because now it is
i don't i don't know what you're trying
to bribe me to do but i'm not gonna do
it
i will say thank you for the super chat
though i appreciate you
good stuff
who else we got before we hop into it
um aaron does it need to be closed
is it an open buggy or an elephant seat
uh is within the rules
um
look
this one we tried to really keep it as
simple as possible we got four simple
rules keep it moving to the right
so yeah sure it could be open as far as
that rule goes capture the sense of
movement of course it can still be open
add at least one custom character and
don't touch the camera yes it can be
open for sure um we kept these rules as
simple as possible for you to just have
as much creative freedom as possible as
long as you have
um a character in your scene
and you maintain uh this window
essentially
then you're good
you're good to go
it's a travel montage i think as long as
you guys know that we're we're gonna be
in a good spot
okay i'm sure i'm missing a couple
things but you know we're gonna we're
gonna get into examples from the
community from you guys
uh maybe halfway through the stream
but let's get started let me show you
what i have here in photoshop what i
created here in photoshop
so basically i just
put together this sketch
to try and capture
the vibe of my scene to see what i'm
going for
um i'm using
pure ref as well
that's a great program for
gathering reference material and let me
load up
what i'm referencing right now
right so
we got mad max we got interstellar
star wars alien um this is from the
movie sunshine
up here
all right so i don't know if i'm gonna
go for a
spaceship kind of vibe
or if i'm going to go for more of like a
mad max
wasteland truck kind of vibe
and it might be a split between the two
i'm looking at of course
you know
fighter jet cockpits and whatnot you can
see how
this little console here how it ramps up
i'm using that right in here so that's
where i stole that
and then of course like
for sunshine the sunshine reference you
see all these monitors up top right
so you can see i threw those in and
basically i'm going to record this with
the rococo
smartsuit pro 2
right
and i want it i want to be able to like
okay so here's the idea here's here's
the pitch here's the pitch
so basically
it's a character getting into a chair
strapping up locking in
hitting all the switches
um
you know like cranking all the levers
moving all the buttons as the engine is
like
starts up a little camera shake
um
you see you hear the engine start to rev
and they're stationary at this point
they're stationary since my render is
starting it off i'm gonna start it
stationary and then ramp up into all the
other renders
and then basically once it's all armed
and ready to go strapped in
we're gonna
blast off
and i'm gonna have a bunch of like
little dangly
trinkets and ornaments
in this person's vehicle
spaceship
so that when they start taking off
you see all of them start to like move
backwards and i i really want to capture
that sense of like
just thousands of pounds of pressure
pushing you back into your seat
and blasting you off and then maybe
there's going to be a secondary blast
where it goes like even more intense
and then it goes boom right into the
rest of the renders
so
my goals are to capture the
the g-forces
and to build out this cockpit
uh
in a way that isn't too over ambitious
but allows me to one make it feel like
this character's cockpit like it's their
ship or their car
so i need to personalize it and i also
need to
figure out a way and design it in such a
way that all of these buttons and
switches are accessible within arm's
reach when i have the rococo suit on
right i'm gonna be like switching and
moving all these levers and i'm gonna
actually have to set up
like here
in my little room here i'm gonna have to
set up
like a makeshift little cockpit and
actually have to twist some water bottle
caps or something i don't know what i'm
gonna do
we'll get there that might be stream
three
uh we're doing this every single week
so that's the idea and that's what i
tried to sketch out here i really wanted
to see if i could make this work
i started very simple
let's see yeah i started very simple
and let me just walk you through my
process here
this was a great way for me to actually
like
see if the idea that i had in my head
would be able to come across visually
alright so i just
from the ground up
i like this background i don't know i
just got a chalkboard background so i
threw it in there this is the original
template right
so i and this was the uh boundaries for
the window
and i came in and i basically just you
know sketched up this pilot here
of course using the wacom intuos pro
tablet which you guys can win
for the first uh third second first
second and third place gets away common
tools pro tablet
and yeah it's um it's great for
sketching as you can see because i just
sketched this thing out i have different
arm positions to make sure that like
you know this person can reach
different parts of the vehicle
boom
there's a little overlay
and
i just kind of sketched out the cockpit
here
filled in the window added a little bit
of shading just to be able to tell like
what the heck is going on and then of
course you know i like
i don't know that's not obvious
for some reason i moved it to the left
um gave it a little bit more shading on
the guy and then this is the of course
this is the thumbnail version where you
like
super just you crunch it down super hard
you make everything
uh super contrasty and unsharp mask the
heck out of it
and then i wanted to add some speed
lines and like
you know spice up that hand a little bit
so this is the idea
um and i highly suggest y'all do
something similar if you hadn't done it
already and you're just well on your way
then hey no worries keep going
for me i wanted to make sure that
i didn't jump into something that like
wasn't going to work if i'm going to
spend a month of my life
doing this i want to make sure that it's
like the coolest thing possible and it
pushes me this is gonna be a challenge
for me no doubt
um from the modeling alone yeah it's
gonna be a challenge
but also the character that's the
biggest thing i'm worried about is the
character and i'm sure a lot of y'all
are
too about to figure out how to make this
character look good i don't know if i'm
gonna do a photo scan and limit it to
just simple movements like this
but having some cloth physics would
definitely be the coolest possible thing
um
so i'll have to figure that one out
and i'll let you know again throughout
these weeks i'ma let you know how it
goes and the things i figure out
so yeah really doing this
this concept helped out a lot now if you
look at these references i'm going to be
coming back to these a ton
and this is crucial this is so crucial
right
for
actually like guiding your path
guiding what you're doing
because i could just make this up in my
head
and it would be like okay
it probably wouldn't feel
real if i just made it up in my head i'm
no kim jong-ji that guy if you don't
know who kim jong-ji is
youtube that guy that dude's a master
but yeah having a reference like this
y'all know i say it every time
it's the key to making your stuff look
recognizable
and grounding it in some sort of reality
like these rivets here on the side of
the spaceship is incredible
this is from alien
what a crazy
shot here
the fact that they did this for real
she's in this actual
this power loader i don't know what it's
called
and then of course you have the alien
here like
movies man movies won't be like this
they aren't like this anymore
or they're very rare that's for sure
this is just a close-up of some buttons
to see some wear and tear i'll i know
i'll need that later
um
some helmet ideas top gun
and of course we have a car here with
some roll cages built in i think i'm
gonna do that as well i'm gonna take
this roll cage design
combine something like this
with something like this
so that's all i know right now i told
you guys everything i know
hans
shout outs to you
i appreciate you uh super chat in there
super cool it will be your first time
creating a character
you know it's gonna be my first time too
i've always just done photo scans
i think this time is really gonna be a
challenge for me so we're in it together
brother i appreciate the super chat very
kind of you
we got 1200 people up in this chat right
now that's what's up
heck yeah
welcome everybody
so let's get cranking um by a show of
hands
who is
already working on their submission give
me a thumbs up
if you
want to join this challenge but haven't
downloaded the files yet
give me
a smiley face
and
if you're one of those people putting a
smiley face down right now
then click that link in the description
because i got you covered it's gonna
take you the discord the discord server
is is our hub for this entire thing it
has all the technical rules it has
everything you need to know it has the
download files etc etc
so hop in there
download the template file you're going
to see something like this we have we
have versions for i'm not going to say
everything but we have blender we have
c4d we have an fbx we have unreal engine
uh we have unity we have maya
right now so
whatever you can get your hands on we
got a lot of thumbs ups that's good to
see
wait clarice there's a clarice file
really
oh my god
y'all people are hooking it up i know
there's an unreal five file out there
somewhere floating around there's a
clary's file for sure too i really
appreciate y'all a good community
yeah we got tons of thumbs ups this is
awesome people from india hanging out
shout outs to y'all in india i know it's
late out there but i really appreciate
y'all making this one
all right
let's try and block this thing out
[Music]
all right
oh i know what i'm going to do i'm going
to add
i'm going to add my sketch
to my references here
so i can actually like
so i can see
what's going on
okay i'm close here like i'm certainly
close but i want to by the end of the
stream i want to have a block out that
like is the official block out
where i can start going into detail on
right i want to do the most broad
strokes that's what we're doing we're
bob ross in the first five minutes right
now and we're laying down our our you
know
our base coat
you know we're getting the whole the
whole canvas covered in paint right now
and the paint colors that we think
uh
that we know we're going for
right
based off of our reference
so if we get to that point we can get
those broad strokes and
maybe let's work on this roll cage
because i like the idea of this being a
really really really really fast rocket
car
um
so
i want it to have elements of of the car
to it
and having the roll cage be in there is
is probably uh
probably a good thing to do
right
that'll really kind of give it that car
feel
um
so i'll add a little bit of this here
these welded pipes and whatnot
i think having some like little mirrors
off to the side that'll be some good
detail that we'll do later
and maybe there's like a
i don't know maybe we do a windshield
like this or something
i'll have to figure that one out
but now you're going to just watch me
struggle for the next hour
so buckle up y'all
i hope you're all working on your
renders and have a good one
[Music]
so if y'all are in c4d
i'm using uh
zero hockey zero
to grab this little tool over here
the rectangular selection tool and it
actually grabs uh
points that you can't see i really use
it for that it's very handy
now i am but
at modeling
i can only do the most basic of models
i feel like my
expertise lies in
like the lighting the atmosphere
i'm really
i'm setting myself up for for a good
challenge here but hey that's the whole
point of this thing is to push ourselves
out of that comfort zone just a little
bit
okay
so i'm trying to work on a windshield a
front windshield right now
so this character
um
uh
jorn is from mixamo it's just a stand-in
template character
comes rigged and everything so
makes the most definitely a great
resource
i'm sure a lot of y'all know
um
neighborhood what up yo thank you for
the super chat you're saying you're not
a 3d artist but
um my work and the community projects
are next level hey i really appreciate
that i try
um the community project's no doubt
like those are absolutely incredible
it's so cool to see everyone
put their hardest uh
best work into that month and then have
them be combined together it's like the
sickest thing ever
can't wait to see the submissions for
this one same dude same
thank you for the super chat
neighborhood
and uh firefox browser account
shoutouts um
okay sajal
is your girlfriend and you are
you are very happy that you guys are
together that's awesome
shout out to
sajal and firefox browser
um
your name is lakesh
lakeshin shijal
holding it down for the rest of us
thank you for the super chat appreciate
you
all right
hmm
i'm so trash at modeling but you
know we're gonna get we're gonna get
through it we're gonna get through it
so i set up this little um spline
extrude bull situation
to be able to tweak the shape of my
window easily
so that's going to come in handy for
sure
[Music]
[Music]
all right and yeah i'm actually using
the little doodle tool to make sure it's
staying within the actual window
um
which is a great little tool in c4d i'm
in uh
r25 here
and right at the bottom there's the
doodle paint tool
and i'm just using that to
just as a reference here in my scene it
helps out a lot
so once i get my uh john malcolm yo
what's up man hey
so you feel that the roll cage section
should really all have the same profile
slash diameter 100 dude this is just the
block out i'm like these these aren't
final pieces i'm just getting the the
shape and feel of this right now
um so right now y'all can see that
this template window
outline is different than the shape of
my actual window
and that's okay you know i mentioned
this earlier in the stream but
uh
we know that based on the vehicle you
choose for your
for your scene that shape will change
that's just a given right there's no car
that has this square window
um unless it's like a limousine or
something i i don't know
um so as long as you maintain like
roughly the same visual weight as this
outline you're gonna be set
so no need to worry there
right
and again it's this window this central
large window that is the cutting point
between all of these renders
so we're gonna be match cutting using
this window
as that central focus point
3d gala what's up yo good to see ya
thanks for making it out and thank you
for the super chat very kind of you so
you're curious why is this challenge 69
instead of a cinematic ratio
like alternate realities was is it just
to simplify things and reduce
disqualifications or is there another
reason there's actually a couple of
reasons the first reason is because
it was difficult to find the right
balance
between the character and this window
and if we were to go 16-9 on this
meaning if i were to change this to
1920x810
you'd see it cuts off this top window
and i wanted i wanted the entire window
to be in the frame and not just
leave frame like that
right
um and it scrunt it totally scrunched
our doodle there um
like this looks cool no doubt
um but i would prefer to have the window
in and to just have more
on screen essentially
um so that was the main reason another
reason too is youtube also doesn't have
the ability to add um like annotations
or anything to videos
that are natively uploaded in sixteen
nine
or uh sorry not not 69 235 235
which is really
they need to fix that
they definitely need to fix that
so
yeah those are a couple of reasons as to
why we did it there may have been
another that i can't think of right now
was there another
um i don't think so but it is a very
standard ratio
that people are pretty familiar with so
that has it going for it as well
but thanks for the question and the
super chat and uh digital ape 2000 thank
you very much for the super chat thank
you very much dude you've got amazing
content i'm super excited since it's my
first time watching your stream yes yes
welcome welcome to the stream thank you
for the support
um if you're not subscribed already then
subscribe
and uh yeah i'm gonna be filling it up
with lots of good stuff you're gonna see
more streams like this
throughout this entire month as we're
doing the infinite journeys challenge
and you know what digital you should
totally uh you should join us you should
challenge yourself
um
all right
let's get back to this thing
it's tough you know it's streaming is
tough
i don't know how people do it you know
i i've never tried playing a game in
streaming because i think by playing the
game and screaming at your friends
that might be entertaining in itself but
what i'm trying to do here is a little
bit different
i'm trying to
get you all inspired i'm trying to
educate you all as much as i can
and doing that
while also
trying to get work done myself
it's difficult it's difficult i'm not
gonna lie
it takes a lot of a lot of focus
ah this geometry is horrible but you
know what it's all good it's only a
blockout
stanked even is that the name stanked
even that's quite the name um much love
for the super chat
will there be a live stream of the
submissions
there will be there absolutely will be
yeah we're gonna do a live judge we'll
do top 100 live judging
um
stream in like the very beginning of
march basically
where we we will unveil the top 100 and
reveal
the five winners who are winning a bunch
of crazy stuff
um we got looking glasses we got rococo
smartsuit pro twos
um with with the gloves tracking and
everything we got
an all-expenses paid trip to camp
mograph here in the us we got wacom
intuos pro tablets we got mograph.com
courses
um
we got max on one subscriptions we got
uh
i goodness what else do we have um
i think i said everything the sponsors
they're they're down in the description
if you want to check them out see what
y'all can win um
but it's gonna be nuts and the prizes
are international too so you don't have
to be in the u.s to win these
sam yo what's up thanks for the super
chat
should convince peter to participate
you know i would i feel weird asking
friends to like hey you should do this
you should
join this challenge that i set up i
don't know
i would love for everyone to do this
challenge
and having friends do them it's a very
nice
little like
little secret little reward you know as
i'm going through looking at stuff like
oh
i know this person it feels good it's
cool
and we got uh
digital ape
once again thank you very much you're
working on it right now i love it making
a steampunk robot on a train going by
steampunk city that's what i like to
hear
that sounds awesome
rudy pov good night
enjoy that slumber that sweet sweet
slumber
okay
all right let's see if i can't just take
this piece here
and break it off with up
bring it out of the bowl there
this will be our windshield
just a rough block here of what we're
doing
[Music]
hitting w to switch between local and
world orientation
we want to flip those normals
with ur is going to flip your normals
so orange is correct and blue
is incorrect
now you're coming through my speakers
hold on
i think people can hear you say hello
soto
all right let me try and get you in my
ear here one second
sodamonte holding it down
oh let's see
yo
yeah
sweet
all right back at it
all right so let's solo this thing i'm
just going to select it
so whoa hold on now
i think that was the wrong one
what just happened
there we go
um we gonna solo it
looking good all right let's make some
slices
very simple here um we'll go one down
the middle holding shift that's gonna
lock that right down the middle and by
the way this is ul i'm hitting
kl rather that's your loop path cut tool
you can right click and get it down here
holding shift get it right up in there
um let's go to uh hit nine that's going
to be your main selection tool we'll
select both of those
and i believe it's mw
for
nope nope nope it's been a minute hold
on
m no okay hold on i gotta
get my mind right it's been a minute
since i've been in c4d um
extrude inner
i think that's what i'm looking for
oh no i was right it was inset
mw
no i'm still chilling sweet
all right you see how it's bringing in
like that i want to have that central
divider so we need to check uncheck
preserve groups
boom
get rid of those wendy's you know what
let's give it some depth so i'm going to
hit d for extrude and just kind of push
it back
and let's undo that we want to uncheck
create caps
there we go and then i'll delete those
cool
on solo
hop back into camera and see what it
looks like okay so we have a window up
there
i think we need to
bring it down a little bit
there we go something like this
jonko
hit me with the super chat thank you
brother appreciate your first time
watching the stream and starting my
second month using blender so excited to
see everyone work yes yes
that's what's up welcome to the stream
welcome to the channel um
yeah i hope you're having a good time i
hope blender is going all right for you
um i know it's a great program and a lot
of people here use it
so keep up the good work and i hope
you're joining this challenge this is
like the best way to learn how to use a
program is to give yourself a reasonable
amount of time we have a month
and a challenge that's what you got and
it's going to be sweet so
keep it up man i hope you're doing it i
hope you're doing the challenge
thank you for the chat i appreciate you
and save polar bears i'm down for that
i'm down
uh thank you also for the super chat
this is your first render challenge as
well and your first time getting into
any 3d program blender as well yes yes
hey if this is your first challenge and
your first time getting into 3d give me
a shout out give me a thumbs up
that's awesome
um and seeing how you navigate through
all these different options and menus is
so confusing to watch hey i appreciate
you uh saying that
yeah so
this is how i like to think of it right
so
basically
when you first start a program and you
open it up for the first time
you are
paralyzed
you don't know what to do you can't move
anywhere because you don't know where to
go you don't even know how to crawl yet
but
you downloaded the program because you
were excited about creating 3d in the
first place right
so the way i think of it is like you you
have
a fire burning inside
um that's like yo we got to do something
about this urge to create 3d stuff right
so you downloaded blender
and i'm sure you found some tutorials
you found some youtube channels
such as this one maybe blender guru um
maybe a little bit of ian hubert maybe
some cg geek you know there's a lot of
different youtube channels
that uh are 3d based um my my channel is
kind of like a bunch of different
programs i mainly use c40 and unreal
um
and then you have programs dedicated to
certain
certain programs like blender like
blender guru right so you did that
you're
you're following basically what you want
to do
you're finding the things that get you
excited and you're doing it so you're
doing this challenge which is amazing i
love it
like i said it's a great way to learn
and get
you know just to dive in
and start knocking out um
some of those creative goals that you
have
right
but when you say
going through these menus and it gets
really confusing
hang in there okay hang in there because
when you first start the program getting
back to my uh my my uh my example from
before
you're frozen you don't even know how to
crawl yet
but the more you learn how to navigate
the program i think that's the first
thing is just learning how to navigate
the program watch a tutorial on how to
navigate blender and where stuff is
please do that because then you can at
least start crawling and now you know
where the kitchen is now you know where
the living room is now you know where
the bedroom and the bathroom are the
garage right so you know you can get
into these different rooms but there's a
lot of different things in those rooms
too
so you have to dive deeper into those
rooms and pull out all the drawers and
there's all these little things in each
drawer right so
take it step by step and just know that
like
as you
as your creative
passion drives you
to stay in the program you're going to
unlock new things in that program
my biggest
piece of advice would be
to know it takes time and to also learn
your shortcuts learning your shortcuts
is like the the cheat code it's the
secret to
you know to fl to eventually getting to
the point where you're flying around the
program you can skip steps you can go
from
crawling
to a fast walk you know if you learn
your shortcuts and it's going to help
you get ahead of the game so please
learn them
they're available online and they
probably in blender it says probably
says what the shortcuts are so
um
yeah learn your shortcuts definitely
learn your shortcuts they help out a lot
but anyway
say polar bears thanks for the super
chat appreciate you
all right this window needs to come down
maybe something like that
when i was younger and even still now
still at this point
i would get really like
bummed about my drawings
because my drawings didn't look as good
as i
wanted them to look
when i was like
halfway through the process even a
quarter into the process like oh my
drawing doesn't look good
and i'm only a quarter of the way in i'm
not done with it yet but it doesn't look
good
and that would really discourage me
and
worst case scenario is you you stop
drawing that's the worst case scenario
or in this case
you know we're creating a 3d scene and
this doesn't look good
i got geometry all over the place this
kind of sucks
but it's okay you know it's gonna be
okay you just need to keep taking time
and keep putting time into it keep
working on it
keep massaging it right
and it's gonna turn out it's gonna look
sick in the end
you just gotta know that it's gonna look
sick in the end
and
the best way to kind of work that muscle
is to
do it often
which you know brings me to i don't know
this is we have a weekly challenge
excuse me this kombucha you know
too much kombucha just
on the discord server we do weekly
challenges
and those help artists really work those
muscles every single week
right now we're not doing them because
we're doing this monthly challenge the
infinite journeys challenge
but as soon as this is over
we're going to be popping off weekly
challenges and we're even thinking about
doing a yearly challenge
uh which i can't wait to tell you more
about
um
and just on that subject you know we're
gonna do monthly we're trying to do like
monthly themes as well
to help artists really
have uh you know a direction of like
what they can start working on and stuff
so
keep working at it just keep working at
it it's gonna be alright
it's gonna be okay
we got another super chat
um peter
yo
my goodness very kind of you thank you
thank you so much for that super chat so
you're saying blender
you have electricity cuts one times or
two times per day
okay okay so you got power outages
once or twice a day is there a way to
increase render time
um
like by like lowering the quality of the
assets or uh a faster video format and
then maybe
uh format video online for size looking
for options no blender render farm
well let's see
let me
okay so sodamonte
is up in up in my ear right now he's
telling me there's a free render car
render farm called sheepit
um which you can use and check out also
i would recommend
a um
like a battery backup system
if you have the ability to get that
um we had them at corridor and they
basically
it's basically a brick it's a big old
battery which which you plug your
computer into
and then you plug that battery into the
wall
i believe that's how it works and then
you're running your computer right
through the wall but if the power goes
down the backup battery system it boots
up and it keeps your computer going for
however long it needs to go for or until
the power comes back on so i would
definitely look into a backup battery
system
um and then that sheepit render farm
if you're trying to do a little bit of
interfarm action so hopefully that helps
you
and we got mg as well shout outs
for the super chat no not even a message
just a shout out what's good mg thank
you i love your picture
i'm down for some sloths it looks like
either a sloth or a penguin either or
i'm down
all right so let's take my own advice
and not give up on this blockout because
it's looking chunky right now
[Music]
and then maybe we have like this central
piece
ctrl drag to duplicate
and we just hit t for scale
go wide with it
bring it to the
end is your dashboard essentially
i can see how this would connect easily
right up in there that can connect
nicely
let's see what that looks like
i'm not i'm not upset with that you know
i'm gonna be honest i am not upset with
that it looks cool
um i think we can get some nice little
dashboard readouts here we can get
dashboard readouts here we can get some
monitors a little lcd screen situation
coming up all up in here
um
i'm happy with that dash that looks cool
um
let's maybe like
let's see if we can't like
no the angle is cool too i dig the angle
hitting zero holding down shift
and let's open these up
that's pretty sweet i dig that
cool
cool cool
cool cool
all right
1100 people chilling working out on our
renders i dig it i dig it very much
i'm gonna get to some community
works in progress very soon i'm going to
show you some works in progress that
different artists have done on the
discord server
and show you what i like about them
now if you have your works in progress
that you want to send me i'm going to be
shouting out different works and
progresses every um
every stream essentially right
so i'd love to just
you know keep showing off all the cool
renders that you guys are working on
every single stream i'll do it about the
middle of the stream we're getting close
i'm gonna keep working for a little bit
and then i'll get back to work i'm gonna
try and finish my block out and then
we're gonna hop into the weekly uh
winners it's the it's the very last
weekly challenge it was uh when um
technology meets nature
is the prompt
um so i'll reveal the five winners who
completely unlocked the discord server
it's a full discord server i got the
patreon link in the description
um the the five dollar tier the lowest
tier unlocks the full server for you
guys
um and of course the professional tier
you have your own little section there
on the discord
um
so
yeah otherwise it's open right of course
you can get in for free for this
challenge and for the weekly challenges
you don't need to pay anything to do
that i just want to help
y'all work as much as possible
um so
i wanted to keep those open
all right let's get back to it
editor-in-chief
brother you're struggling to come up
with an idea um
heard dude heard
i feel ya okay so here's how i came up
with my idea
i
i mean honestly the way i came up with
my idea is by taking breaks two weekends
ago
i i uh went with my buddy marcus
and
we went to go to the blue angels
practice
and if you don't know who the blue
angels are they are like some of the air
force's top pilots
and
they do some crazy stuff i'll show you a
video here in a second
i love jets i mean from the
since i was like three i wanted to be a
jet fighter pilot and um i feel like
this is cliche at this point but no joke
i'm color blind so i they said no
couldn't do that later found out
that a buddy of mine his uncle is an
astronaut or was an astronaut
which means you had to fly fighter jets
before you fly you know spaceships
so
he's colorblind too and he was he just
said no
they're like you're colorblind you can't
do this and you just said no and i guess
he just did it i i don't know how that
works but he did it
um so i love jets i love speed um
i flew these stunt jets in
in vegas for a thing and
that was about the craziest thing i've
ever done in my life
i hit six g's
my
vision
came in like this tunnel vision my
eyeballs were open
but all i could see was a quarter just
and then that quarter went away and it
was darkness and my eyeballs were open
but i saw nothing
that was awesome
luckily i didn't pass out
um
and then
yeah anyway you guys know i love going
fast so jets that's the thing and then
last week i went rock climbing with my
buddy jan
and it just gave me time away from the
computer to think about what i want to
do so i knew that i wanted to
do something
with speed hence this challenge right i
love i love travel montages who doesn't
it's a good time
so everything just kind of came together
in my in my free time um and of course
hopping in on the discord and talking
with y'all about different ideas we had
a little um
little town hall meeting where everyone
came in and shared what they were trying
to do and we got a chance to brainstorm
and come up with stuff together so that
helped out a lot
we should do those once a week
that's very helpful
and actually we do have idea starters in
the get started channel on discord as
well so
take a look at those and see if that
doesn't you know spur any ideas for you
um you got pinterest you know check out
pinterest go for a walk
those will be my my suggestions for now
let me show you these jets though let me
show you how cool this is
so
on my instagram i posted that the second
loudest thing i ever heard in my life
was a harrier jet landing right above my
head that was terrifying um
but let me show you the loudest thing i
ever heard in my life
all right let me see let me see let me
see
um soto do i have desktop audio or no
okay
all right let me let me see if i can
find this
video for you guys
okay
this video right here loudest thing i
heard in my life
look at this
we got four blue angels jets
coming at me
on the runway full blast
all the smoke and gasoline in the
background
right landing gear is up
this dude straight up drifts his jet
and right over the head
god that was so i was so loud
i had my uh my shooting ear protection
on that's supposed to make guns like not
a thing
dude
it's like i wasn't even wearing them
look at this guy look at this dude drift
on the far left let him drift
he's like
and he's like
chilling
oh man that was a cool day
that was a cool day
and then they're doing stuff like just
crazy stuff like this
absolutely amazing
god love me some jets
i know i get amped i am amped for top
gun too
i cannot wait for that movie
these guys are just chilling
anyway jets i love jets
so that was just that was me on a break
i was taking a break and like
my creative as i'm thinking about it
behind the computer
that stuff kind of catches up with me
when i'm taking a break so
make sure y'all are taking breaks
all right back to it back to it
i'm hitting s by the way
that'll snap the viewport boom to
whatever i have selected
that one's a lifesaver no doubt
sweet i'll probably have a little like
trinket dangling from right here
[Laughter]
in fact i'm gonna throw it in right now
i'm gonna just throw in a little test
trinket
um
where are you at let me go to my assets
here
where are you at
oh there you are
my little penguin
here he is
little buddy
that's a lot of penguins
if you look closely
this little guy
was in my parallel dimensions render
but you'll have to find him
i'm not telling you where he is
i'm going to use the transfer tool so i
have the little penguin selected shift c
and we're going to go transfer
which let's just dock that up in there
because we're going to need it
all right so with penguin selected
transfer tool we'll define anything in
here any i just need to get it in my
viewport
boom there we go
and we're chilling
r for rotate hold shift to snap
180 and let's get this bud up in there
or shrink him down a little bit
he'll be chilling you know like the old
eight ball
hanging from your rear view mirror
so we'll we'll figure that out and maybe
even throw in a rear view mirror
i don't know
do spaceships have rear view mirrors
probably
mine will i know that
uh hold ctrl
with an object selected to spawn
whatever you want on that object
so wait we got our rear view we got our
penguin chillin
and we can probably drop that down
there we go
i love it yeah
getting somewhere
brendan yo brandon huskin thank you for
the super chat we got thumbs ups all the
way around thumbs ups to you brother
appreciate you
hope you're working on your submission
if not
what's stopping you jump on in
vj yo v j verma
huge shout outs to you man thank you so
much for the very very kind super chat
that's awesome not even
not even a message just a straight up
little rocket blast i love it thank you
thank you thank you so much
shout outs to you man really appreciate
it did i miss anybody else i don't think
so
i think we're good
we're chilling
carter d films yes you found the penguin
found the penguin
i like it i like it a lot
sub hudra you're sleepy you gotta go
good night thanks for hanging out with
us
ten not ten thousand not ten thousand
people we got 1 000 people
chillin in the chat that's a good group
very very good group
appreciate you all for hopping in with
me
boom okay we're looking we're looking
pretty good here um i like this
dashboard setup now what i want to work
on is this bottom area
and i need to work on some sort of roof
like
levers and stuff on the roof so let me
hide the roll cage for now
um
[Music]
that's our character
cool cool cool
let's hide this roll cage the roll cage
is gonna we'll come back in and
use that to support in a minute
hmm
i mean the easy the easy way on this is
to just extend these out i don't know if
that's what i want to do
if i want to cheat it you know i could
do both sides of this
thing
holding shift to select all these
different pieces t for scale
back into camera
yeah that's
that's a lot now that could just be
buttons and panels and stuff but like
i'm trying to imagine what else could be
there
i know
i think it could open up a little bit
more
like that is fine i know i want to grab
these two bits
and move those
see this whole bit right here yeah let's
move all this up
and this guy can
open up just a touch
d for extrude
i'll extrude that down just a bit
something like that
and i'll probably
let's solo it real quick
and i want to even out you see how this
is uneven right here it's slanting down
i want to keep them even so here's my
trick for this basically i'll just
select these two edges
and uh scale this down to zero
and then they'll even out they'll be
perfectly in line
so that's that's one i use all the time
it's looking cool yeah i'm definitely
gonna come in here and inset all this
um
so let's let's do that
right now
mw
or inset
now we want the opposite of what we did
on the windshield so we'll preserve the
groups
and i'm probably gonna do a thing where
like
this is getting into detail at this
point but i'll go in a little bit
i'll go in some more
pull it back
let's see let's go let's go in more
pull it back like that yep and then go
in with it
in set
probably something like that and then
we'll put like different commands and
screens and dials there
um swirly sticks thank you for the super
chat
you say um any advice for anyone getting
into 3d yes absolutely i talked about it
just a little earlier
but i'll say it again because it's
important
um
you're not going to get into 3d if you
don't want to if you want to get into 3d
you will um
so it seems like you have an interest
you're here you're watching the channel
appreciate you thank you so much
um
you're getting excited about 3d now you
want to create some 3d
uh blender is like i mean it's it's free
right and it's very powerful so it's
probably the most accessible way to jump
in also you got unreal engine that's a
little
a little complicated i think start with
blender
watch channels like blender guru um
obviously i'm not going to say don't
watch my channel come back for the
streams we're doing this
every single week this month but usually
it's once a month and then i have a
pre-edited video uh during that month as
well so it's usually a two video month
this week is a four video or sorry this
month is a four video month
and uh
find the things that like get you
excited recreate the things that you
want to recreate build the things you
want to build
on the discord server we have weekly
challenges those will help you every
single week with a new prompt
and give you some some recognition as
well i shout out the top five winners of
that weekly challenge which by the way
they win full access to the discord
server even the patreon pro
channels as well
so um you can get full access to the
server
and but also the weekly challenges i
shout out honorable mentions as well
people who are like oh that was a great
idea or that looks really cool you did a
really cool thing there
keep it up right so it's a good way to
like keep your passion going and to also
be challenged every single week
to your skill level right
and then do this challenge please if you
hadn't already download the starter
files um i have an announcement video
that you can check out that was last
week's upload
and then i have a link in the
description
uh which leads you to the discord
and to the download files
and you'll see something like this
right
and i'm building mine out right now to
look like
this
all right so
each and every one of us are doing a
different little thing here and i love
it i love it
yeah i just know it takes time
right
swirly sticks it takes time
just keep that passion alive keep having
fun with it have as much fun as possible
uh and then we got iron
fowl
fountainer music
yo thanks for the super chat appreciate
you
thank you for motivating me to keep
pushing the boundaries i've learned so
much on the last challenge let's rock
this one yes
yes let's rock it i'm glad you're
excited i'm excited i can't wait to see
everyone's renders it's going to be nuts
goodness it's going to be awesome
mr t
how am i going to stitch all these
together
well
in davinci resolve of course and put
them next to each other one after the
next one after the next one after the
next and
organize them all into different vehicle
categories and
add some really cool music and add
everybody's names alongside it and then
upload it to youtube and
that'll be one and then we'll do the top
100 i'll go through
all of these submissions and choose the
top 100 artists do the top 100 montage
custom music for it usually
i'm trying to get a custom artist right
now
to do custom music on it so
it's going to be sweet
it's going to be sweet
okay
maybe we should check out the community
renders right now the community works in
progress and see how y'all are doing
all right
let's see
so
first up let's go okay let's go with
edge
so edge
is doing
this one here it's a similar idea you
know you got the speed thing that you
got going there um it looks like you're
doing a drift actually which i like
nice little drift action
um and you're just piecing this is your
this is your block out which i really
dig you i can't believe
you got the animation already that's
craziness
um
but you see what edge is doing he took
the window he changed the shape of it
but he kept the visual weight of that
window center framed and large
just like the template
he turned it to a car he's focusing on
one character
he's showing the sense of speed with the
poles in the background everything in
the background really gives off that
sense of speed
um
what else
so you say oh is he touching the camera
is he moving it well you can do a little
bit of camera shake i think a little
camera shake is totally fine
um
now
if you go overboard with it
it you know it might just be too much
you wouldn't want excessive camera shake
like
i don't it has to be tasteful just make
it have it have it be tasteful i think
this what edge is doing here is tasteful
it's well done it's not distracting me
from the scene you're showing the sense
of movement
you're keeping that character
you're moving it to the right
can't wait to see what you do next with
this uh jack the hack
let's see what jack on edge we we we did
this we did this
jack what you got going
oh is this a playlist hold on
let's try this again
cool all right so
jack is doing a cool thing here we got a
little
um prison break
western style prison break i dig it
you got your window
centered up looking real nice
um
kept it pretty darn close
to the template window size if not exact
um
you decided to go for three characters
in your scene very ambitious i dig it
i love your lighting i love your idea i
love your concept i can't wait to see
what else you got going on outside
and i love the story too look
they're about to be hung these dudes i
don't know what they did
but they're about to be hung
and they're not trying to get hung today
so they're like i'm a piece
um
so i like dig your story i dig your
story i can't wait to see what else you
do with this scene and how you spice it
up i'm very excited oh
you got the guys on the right too
these cowboys on the right
i assume they're cowboys
that's pretty cool
i love that
jack keep it up i'm loving your work in
progress man it's looking really really
good
let's see um
we got
corsa vision
with this one here
now this one it looks like you kept the
the window size pretty darn spot on i
like the little extra detail you added
up towards the top
i think that's super solid
and it looks like you raised the floor
up a little bit
to like catch the floor you got your
floor geometry there you have a little
bit of camera shake it's very subtle
it's very very subtle i would say keep
in mind that
the character
who's filming this
are they han is it handheld or is it on
a tripod
i think that will determine your style
of camera shake right now this is
looking like
the camera isn't moving but the vehicle
is moving
that's what it looks like to me
but it's a work in progress
um the story i'm not quite sure
what the story is it looks like a
traveler i could see like a backpack at
the bottom
maybe a map is falling off here
looks like
um
and you got some cool stuff in the
background you got a little block out
background going on you got some
lighting figured out and i can't wait to
see you know what else you do with this
oh you even have a nice reflection of
the opposite side of this train
in the window too i dig that
heck yeah chords of vision good stuff
keep it up keep it up we're gonna do
this every week we're gonna do works in
progress for people every week
conor one of the mods
i think he's in maya
good stuff good stuff
got a little transit scene here
bowling ball head character
smoking through
i hope you have smoke coming through
that bowling ball hole
i hope
and i would love to see him like take a
whiff you know
not a whiff but take a drag and then
see some smoke coming out of all three i
don't know how that's gonna work but
like
i dig what you got going on it's moving
to the right you're capturing the sense
of movement you got a character you have
a little bit of camera shake it's not
excessive and it's jostling the
briefcase on the right it's jostling the
things in the vehicle that's what i love
that's what i want to do for mine as
well
connor good stuff
and then we got one more work in
progress to show off
um adjunction
quite the work in progress my dude um
this has come quite a way in a week's
time
i dig it so what you're doing
is it seems that you're moving the
the wall
back
and we still have the big center frame
window it kind of trails off to the left
and the right you're adding a bunch of
characters and you're filling the space
you're excited you're essentially like
you're growing the space in which the
characters um
are are living in so your foreground is
filled with five characters in this case
your center frame window that's the most
important thing you have your center
frame window it's moving to the right
you're capturing a sense of movement
um it'd be nice to maybe see some like
asteroids fly by or something or just
something to really tell how fast this
ship is moving
um
but there is already a lot going on you
know
you got the dance off going it looks
great i'll dig your render quality and
everything this is super solid and
really funny
so i can't wait to see what else you do
with this
that's gonna be sweet
alright
so i'm gonna keep doing this once a week
i'm gonna
give a little community shout out check
in on you i'll see how you're doing with
your works in progress so please just dm
me on uh
on discord if you have a work in
progress you want me to show off
um i'm happy to go through and and do
that just don't be excessive with it
because i'm gonna have like a thousand
dms
so spare me please
maybe post them in the chat and just add
me or something in the uh
in the infinite journeys chat that might
be a better way to do it
okay let's see let's see if i can't take
this block out to the next level
so we have our chair here
got the head brace make sure this dude's
not going to snap his back
snap his neck when this thing takes off
okay we need some sort of like
system up top here
that he can tap into so let me let me
model that real quick um
starting with the default cube i'm just
selecting anything that's center framed
with the pilot
i'm going to hold ctrl
and
click on that cube i'll spawn a cube
we'll move this up
make some sort of center console
something like
this i'm hitting c to make it editable
so i can come in here and start chopping
it up kl for loop cut
go to edge mode
make a slice
and let's go ahead and grab
in what is this mode called face mode
polygon mode boom let's grab these two d
for
extrude bring those out just a little
bit
and i'll probably do something
like
let's taper these guys one and two
boom tapered
also
want to taper these guys too
so holding shift
you can see i can snap between all these
i'll go the first one and the first one
and same here we'll just do that top one
there and let's go ahead and grab
i'm just literally making this up as i
go
get me up in this thing
there we go
boom
something like that
you know i didn't even need that other
one so let's select it ul and then um
how do i dissolve let's dissolve
where are you dissolve
m n
m n s dissolve
okay something like this can be some
sort of like
console
that i want to have a
let's see with that piece selected let's
make like a lever
so
holding control let's make a cylinder
t for scale bring it down
and let's go
plus
x
something like this
open it up
boom
and without getting too detailed we
don't need to get too detailed right now
let's hold ctrl again we'll make a cube
hit t for scale
bring it up here
let's
flatten it
something like that is gonna work for
what we're doing right now
and i'll just ctrl drag it over to
duplicate
that's really all we need to do for this
lever just to see if this thing like
works and to get it in place
alt g is going to group it
and then l will toggle your um
what is it your gizmo right
so then i can actually rotate this from
this point like this
which is what we want i'll probably move
it up just a touch
all right so we obviously need to lower
it
we want our lever plus this cube
control or alt g
it's our top console
and we'll just lower it until we can
actually see
see it in our render
something like something like this
probably
[Music]
now that is centered up with him maybe
it should be to the right just to touch
so i can bring it to the right
and lower it a little bit more
that looks pretty cool
i'm down
now we need to connect this to
the
roof
somehow
so i think it's as simple as just
let's see
extruding
now if you were this dude
is pro this like is probably going to be
in your way
if you're straight up this dude's
eyeball right now
i don't know like that's pretty cool you
know
maybe it should be a little bit higher
but
who cares because this is the angle
we're doing it from
maybe we can scoot it forward a touch
something like that
i dig it
i think we'll need
maybe another lever
i mean we need levers all over the place
let's be honest
[Music]
something like this maybe
[Music]
build a trapeze bar in here fun
oh that's funny
so we're going to have a bunch of
different buttons and monitors built in
to these pants to this different
paneling here i think just this on the
right this is the only thing here maybe
there's a second person in this vehicle
and this just comes straight down or
something
and it's like the central
center console
hmm
yo
rohan
dropping some good knowledge says
your only competitor must be
you oh that's a good one
that is a good one i couldn't agree more
so just some advice to people
who might be seeing some renders and
like thinking to themselves oh there's
no way i'm going to win this thing
it's there's the chances are so low
there's only five people out of the
maybe 4 000 people who are going to
submit
or 3 000 i don't know how many we have
3800 people working right now
but
look honestly yes such a tiny tiny tiny
tiny fraction of the people who submit
are gonna win top five
um a larger chunk will get into into the
top 100 montage but you know what all of
you are going to get into the allrenders
montage if you can render your file out
properly and it doesn't crash my davinci
program you're going to get in if i have
to start re-encoding all y'all's renders
then
there's a line i gotta draw at some
point
but the point is
the point is to have fun honestly the
points to have fun during this challenge
and the point is to learn as much as
possible if you're comparing yourself
with all these other people then you're
you're just setting yourself back so
please just try and focus on what you
can do
challenge like we're all at different
points on our journey and to compare
yourself with someone who's 10 years
ahead makes zero sense
you got to compare yourself
with yourself
and if you can get ahead of yourself
um
and overcome that personal self
challenge
then that's literally the best thing
that can possibly happen to you
like i don't know what else is better
than that
so
just keep that in mind when you're doing
this through life even
um
constantly i'd compare myself with other
people i'm 30 at this point i'm 30 at
this point
and of course i i've learned a long a
lot of things along the way through my
20s into my 30s
um
and
keeping myself like i am i'm a go-getter
for sure i love challenging myself hence
why we're doing these challenges
um i love working out i love doing yoga
i love pushing myself i love traveling
as far as i can go
but i have to realize at a certain point
like
i can't be discouraged if i don't meet
my expectations i need to set realistic
expectations
and then
you can achieve those and that feels
great if you're setting unrealistic
expectations
impossible for you to achieve then of
course you're gonna get bummed about
that if you're always setting those
ridiculous expectations so just keep it
doable keep it doable push it just the
touch that's what i'm doing during this
month like
i know i can do this
i just gotta i gotta crank and like
i'm gonna learn some things along the
way i'm gonna learn some character stuff
no doubt i'm gonna learn some character
stuff
um and i'm also gonna learn some
animation too so
we're all learning i don't know all the
answers right
if you say you do
i love to chat with you
joshua i got you man
absolutely thanks for the comment much
appreciated i really appreciate
everybody hanging out with me
you guys are awesome
let's keep this block out going i'm
digging where we're at right now so if i
just take this
i don't know if i take this piece here
one two three control drag
is gonna bring this down
then we kind of have built out like a
center console situation
assuming that there's a person
sitting here in the foreground too so if
i took uh
our boy here
let's do
character
duplicate this guy
and moved him over
right just imagining for a moment
that there's another person in this
vehicle
sitting right here
then this center console could make
sense
i might cheat it and just be like
forget the second character i don't need
the second character i want to focus on
the main character
but have this feel kind of like a
central console thing i'm have to figure
out
what i fill this with
it could just be
like readouts
here's a good reference um
tank in the matrix
that's one for sure
it's the guy sitting in the chair with
all the monitors and stuff
he's got monitors up here he's got
monitors all around right
so maybe there's a there's like some
kind of
pc monitor
thing
down here
that's that's like mounted
to some sort of the roll cage
mounted to the roll cage i like that i
like things mounted to the roll cage
that could be sweet
and there's a bunch of wires coming out
the back and stuff like that could be
sweet
so let's see if we can get that going
select this i'll just make a cube
t for scale
let's make a little monitor
yo sanctivan
what's up thank you for the super chat
super cool dude you said you taught me
so much thanks to you i am able to do
daily renders now thank you for
everything my dude yo thank you i
appreciate you
being here for watching the stream for
the super chat for just being kind and
courteous in the chat i really
appreciate that
um
that you are passionate about what
you're doing and you're spreading that
passion with other people that's what's
up so thanks man keep it up keep it up
i'm excited to see what you do for this
challenge
all right so it's maybe maybe it's
something like this
i don't know
like
i'm just making this up as i go you know
know how we do it
there we go make it editable mw extrude
inner
d for extrude and
scale hit t
we're gonna scale it uh locally so
hitting w to switch between local and
world orientation let's get that down
like that
that's like a little monitor situation
i'll probably use these a lot so i'm
gonna just develop this a little bit
more let's come in
and
like that something like that
and we can probably do like a like three
four monitors
as an aspect ratio
so what i can do is just
hold ctrl let's spawn a plane here hit t
for scale scale it down
and let's use this plane as our
aspect ratio guide so
let's do um
400 with 300 height and then scale that
down
and that is what we want to match
right there
so i imagine this being built from like
old technology so that's why i'm trying
to do like
an older aspect ratio
come on now
come on now
okay
sweet
sweetness
see-through glass display could be cool
absolutely i'm trying to keep this a
little bit more in the vein of uh
you know like this like mad max
it's a see-through glass display could
maybe work for like
some interstellar maybe some star wars
um some sunshine i'm kind of like this
is kind of my vibe right now for
for my console it's very blocky right
very very blocky you got monitors up top
here
with different
little commands and whatnot so
kind of looking at this
mixed with
hey
now with this so like these two
vibes
[Music]
it's like someone took an old an old
like landspeeder kind of situation and
then they threw on some
they retrofitted it with some like
retrofitted what what does that
technically mean retrofitted like
jerry rigged
is to jerryrig and retrofit is that the
same thing
i don't know
anyway
let's get back to it
so the back of the monitor could have
like if i if i keep building this out
it's a block out we don't want to go too
detailed i just want to it's a sketch
it's the 3d sketch is what we're doing
holding control to get the cylinders
there
and we'll get your like component jack
going
something like that and then you have
like your
your power
over here
going in
there i don't know
all right so we'll grab those guys and
alt g to group them and we'll just call
this monitor
hop into camera view and like see what
it looks like
it's in your face
no doubt is in your face
not sure if i want that to be the
situation maybe it's like a smaller
thing
i'll figure out how this works
because i don't want to block
this readout i but i do want something
down here i
i don't know what yet and i don't know
if i need to figure that out now it may
come to me as i'm creating
but having some monitors
strapped down to the actual like
rig itself could be cool
yo spencer what's up dude appreciate the
hangout i think you deserve a raise glad
to learn
uh with this challenge that's what's up
dude i'm glad you learned with this
challenge as well thank you for the
super chat thank you for the support
appreciate you
good times man
are you hanging out are you are you
bouncing
how you feeling how's everyone feeling
if you guys are feeling good give me a
thumbs up
troy i see you too
um you say there's a great video from
ira glass called the gap yes okay that
people starting out should watch very
encouraging
also add some greebles i'll get to them
greebles don't you worry troy i'm going
to tear up them greebles i appreciate
the super chat so
yeah the gap um okay so look up the
video ira glass that's ira
and glass g-l-a-s-s
the gap as far as i
remember
the idea is that we all have an idea of
what we want to create in our heads
we have the references in front of us
obviously you saw me looking through all
these references just now
um
we we see all the greatest movies we've
watched them right um we've played the
most incredible games we've you know
we've played them
so our our library of references in our
head of what we want our creations to
look and feel like
it's maxed out which is great okay
you want the best reference as possible
but your ability
to get there your ability to output
that quality is not there yet it's
definitely not there yet because you
just started
and as years go by
that
gap will get smaller and smaller and
smaller right
so you're achieving this is your bar
that you've set
and this is where you're at and there's
this big gap in between
and as you get better the gap closes and
you know what as you get better you
might find better references and the gap
opens up
but you want to keep working towards
closing that gap and that takes a lot of
time that takes a lot of time i think
they quoted in the in the thing like two
to three years maybe it takes
it could be decades honestly
there's a great book i love it's called
mastery
keep in mind there's two books called
mastery it's the shorter one
um and it's about the idea of like
getting into a hobby let's say you get
into some golf you're like i love golf
you hop into golf you buy the clubs you
get the country club membership um you
get the gloves you get the freaking
all of the
all the the the
golf clubs um
you get golf balls you get it all right
you buy a golf cart i don't know why you
would but you do it
and you play golf for like two months
and you're climbing right this is a
graph of your progress in golf you're
maxing out
two months in you're like dang so much
progress
and then you start to flatline because
like
you reach your limit and now you now
that's where the real training starts
is where okay this is what i'm not good
at so i gotta get better at and most
people once they get to that point
they just boop drop off it's just a
cliff face and they're done
their gloves sit in the freaking garage
they collect cobwebs the golf car
i don't know what you're doing is a golf
car
uh but that's chilling you're not
touching it anymore and you'll never get
good at golf ever again
now here's the thing
we're so addicted to like
getting what we want immediately
that investing time to get good at
something is about one of the hardest
things to do right now especially in the
age we live in with you know of course
with amazon
with social media
you know
you get it all at your fingertips you
know
but you don't get everything at your
fingertips it takes years to master
something so going back to that graph of
progress right you might start in 3d and
you might do some really cool stuff like
this in 3d but then you realize you hit
a gap and i feel like 3d is a little
different i think 3d starts like this
it's almost inverted
and then it kind of levels out again
but like you get to the point where you
start plateauing and you're not getting
better and you're realizing like man why
am i not getting better
but if you keep at it and you have a
solid play like you're doing weekly
challenges you're doing these community
challenges when we do the year-long
challenge you're going to be doing those
too
and you're doing what inspires you and
what you have fun doing that's what
you're going to focus on
and
that bar of progress
it might go up like this every year i
might go
it might just tick up a little bit
and it's going to plateau for another
year it might plateau for another whole
year
but at the end of that year maybe
there's just another little there's a
little tick on that graph of progress
and hopefully that's what these
challenges are for y'all i'm trying to
get that progress bar boop up a little
bit
um
that's what it's like to be a master you
do that for 20 years
you are going to be killing it
killing it i promise you that
so i know that for me that's filmmaking
i want to get better at filmmaking for
the rest of my life 3d
it's not always going to be my main
focus i know that it will it's my main
it's like half of my focus right now of
course i have this youtube channel
teaching you how to do vfx and whatnot
in 3d
um
i love it i love teaching y'all how to
do stuff i love setting up these
challenges in these communities like
this
um
you know but at the end of the day i'm
just trying to learn and grow as much as
possible filmmaking and creating these
this 3d work and doing this stuff is
just a means of like
adding a really powerful tool to my tool
belt that i know i'm going to need when
i'm telling a story
and it all comes back to story right so
the gap
right as you get better and better and
better and when you stick with it don't
drop off stick with it the gap will
close
[Music]
do
[Music]
mr one dead duck
good to see you thanks for the super
chat
so you say suggestion for the bottom
right hand corner
um sent as a direct message
safety caged levers or controls they can
fill the space but not block to view
let's check this dm
oh wow
that's a cool reference i'm gonna take
that thank you i appreciate it
super cool i'll show you guys this in a
second let me just put it in the right
place
got my reference folder
boom
open up pure ref real quick
that's cool man i dig that so you're
saying like these cages here
buttons that you are not trying to press
but you will press at some point
what is all this stuff what is all this
stuff on the roof
that's so cool
oh man this is awesome
see i love it it feels janky it feels
old some indiana jones style
like this is definitely how i want it to
feel
like who knows what this stuff is but it
looks cool
you have different wires and cables and
straps like that's the the micro detail
that we're gonna get to
in our renders but not in the block out
not in the block out we're trying to
just like
create the panels
where this stuff can exist
right
thank you mr owen dead duck
good stuff
good reference
hmm probably work on let's get this roll
cage
going i i i can figure out what to do
down here
later
roll cage
maybe we'll get the roll cage
and then
maybe assess and then pop into the
weekly
weekly winners perhaps
all right let's do this roll cage proper
so it needs to be custom let's do it
with splines
yeah let's do it with splines okay so
i'm gonna hop out of camera view
let's go ahead and
make some splines here so
let's spawn them i'm holding ctrl
let's make a rectangle
spline we'll shrink it up
and let's just get this set up
holding ctrl i'm going to make a circle
spline
t for scale scale that down
and then
rectangle and circle let's put those
guys in a
sweep so holding alt it's been a minute
maybe it's shift alt it's probably shift
alt it's probably control alt who knows
i should
um
put them in a sweep
shift alt
i'm trying to put them both in
the thing
control alt
control alt okay that's what it is to
put both or all selected items in a
sweep
scale down that sphere
and now we just adjust
our rectangle
all right so we need some roll cage
reference
so it's basically going along the door
you have this side of the car as a frame
you have that side of the car
and they're connected
okay i got you i got you
all right so it looks to be like
like a rectangle spline
here
maybe this guy bam rectangle's blind
stand it up
thank you all for hanging out with me we
got 900 people in the chat those are
some
absolutely solid numbers really good to
see
much appreciated y'all all right let's
make that editable
that rectangle is now editable so
let's
duplicate our sweep because we're gonna
need that
awesome
and this will go up
um let's see how far we want that to go
up
i don't know it could be
any one of these
we can adjust that later
i'm just gonna hide the floor for a
second
there we go much better
all right so we need to add some points
here
let's go ahead and hide this console
just so we can work
on this
and
add a point boom
easy
does it
add another point
let's see what we can do with this
basically it's going to start
curving down
here at this point
and this will go
all the way to the edge here
yeah something like that
and of course we'll chamfer these
where are you at chamfer
i know i see you in my peripheral vision
there you are
just a little bit of rounding there
same here
chant for this edge
cool and that's what we'll duplicate
onto the other side
ctrl drag to duplicate
all right and then we connect these
in a couple places so we could do a
connection point
there
i know behind the seats there's usually
like a cross hatch
section
let's make that cylinder go plus x
our radius on this circle is three
point four one six we'll copy that onto
this cylinder
boom
and we'll just use this as our like
connecting bar across this whole thing
sweet so we got one behind the wheel
drop that second one
let's see what we can see
all right so we'll get a cross hatch
maybe in the back
so this one we're not even seeing so i
can just bring this up
and then do a little x here
ctrl drag to duplicate
switch between local and world
orientation
and holding ctrl
to duplicate that
there we go
something like that
and i know it's technically not centered
so maybe we see what it looks like if it
is
i think it looks a little bit better
sweet
digging it
let's maybe see if we can do something
here
now i just don't want to have a bar
right here at the bottom
but maybe it's something i could do
feels a little thick to me
maybe just just a touch um
this is maybe like 2.8
yeah that might feel a little bit better
maybe that's here
maybe not like i'm not i don't love it
but probably on the other side
like right in there or something
and potentially
across the dash
not bad
not bad
yeah that's not bad at all
that's pretty cool
like i'm down this is this feels like a
much cleaner block out than what i had
at the beginning of the stream
i have places for
oh i forgot my
um
where are you
my top console boom yes that feels good
that feels really good to me
i'm excited about that
i might split this window up into little
chunks i don't know yet
and i might make it like a thicker
window um
but we'll we'll see that that's more in
the detail
of everything now if you all
are just joining this challenge
and you don't have anything yet it's all
good you guys have until i believe
february i don't want to get this wrong
let me double check this
on the calendar
you have until
february 27th at 11 59 pm pst
um
so
as soon as it hits monday morning
here in california
it's too late
it's too late
but right now i'm gonna count them you
have
one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 22 23 if i counted correctly
22 to 23 days
to do this all right
so i can't wait to see what y'all do
it's gonna be incredible
um
yeah i don't know i'm feeling good about
my my block out right now
i'm excited for for y'all i'm excited to
see what y'all do
now i'm gonna do the
weekly winners here
for
technology meets nature pretty soon
first let me shout out green apple good
stuff you're learning blender and you
hope you'll be able to participate in
this challenge you're doing great now
dude you're doing great because you're
doing it right now um
i think you can do it no i know you can
do it you say you're learning blender
and hope you'll be able to participate
well by being on this stream and getting
your freaking
brain juices flowing you are
participating i hope to see you render
from you um
for those of you who want to feature or
want your render featured or rather your
work in progress featured next week when
i live stream
um post it in the infinite journeys chat
just at me
uh i'll take a look at your work in
progress and start saving the ones that
i like and featuring them on next week's
live stream
but we ain't done yet
we are not done yet
because we're gonna hop into
the weekly
winners i'm gonna go over those
um might take a five minute break and
maybe i'll hop back into my render we'll
see we'll see how it feels
but um
let's go ahead and do this let's talk
about these weekly winners because we
got
weekly challenges every single week
except for this month because obviously
we're doing
the full on uh
you know the full-on monthly challenge
you can tell you know i start to get
stuttery and i start to like what i'm
saying starts to be long and drawn out
and i start saying the same thing
multiple times that's when i know it's
like okay i'm getting a little fatigued
here
but let's do it let's switch on over
bam we got some challenge winners to
talk about
nature meets technology technology meets
nature
all right we got five winners
first
up in no particular order
we got mr edge
with this amazing render model the
helmet yourself goodness
i love the design of this thing it's
like a mix between iron man and a storm
trooper
your surface imperfections are
ridiculous
your lighting is very simple yet super
effective
and you got the old spear right through
the robo head gotta hurt
uh or does it he's a robot he's a it's a
she robot a he robot it's an it robot i
don't know
um
you know i dig the black and white vibes
here i'm wondering
may i comment on your perfect render
uh i'm wondering
if to give it more of that naturey vibe
if you set it against like a wall of
leaves or something
if that would even be necessary
and it's still a black and white render
you know what i mean
anyway
just random ideas edge congratulations
you got the challenge winner roll this
week you're crushing it can't wait to
see what you do with that race car scene
for infinite journeys keep it up brother
very good stuff moving on to number two
we got elliott with this one i dig it so
much i love your color the color is
super solid your render quality is 100
i'm digging this um what else here
really cool idea i've always wanted to
bring a tv a crt tv out while i go
camping and play smash bros
um zero lag it's the way to go
but dude i think you killed it with this
uh with this environment here
your trees look great
your foliage looks great your scene
looks great
i wanna be in this spot right now i
think that'd be amazing
so congratulations to you elliott for
winning the challenge this week you
brought technology and nature together
you did it you got the challenge winner
roll
you're gonna have full access to the
entire discord server all the way
through the weekly challenge i'm sorry
all the way through infinite journeys
because we're not doing weekly
challenges this month it's infinite
journeys time
moving on
we got
the one and only
boom
juice tin
justin
justin
with this gundam render i love it
very reminiscent of the uh
the classic castle in the sky
by studio ghibli
um holding a bird's nest
that's a nice little
little addition there i love your colors
i love your lighting
i would frame this on my wall
this is absolutely beautiful justin
congrats you got the challenge winner
roll this week you're crushing it hold
on to it for the entire month
got the whole server unlocked to you
congratulations brother
keep it up
i hope to see your infinite journeys
submission as well
noah
yes noah i love this man you know i was
going back and forth between this one
and another one you'll see him in the
honorable mentions here
but i just love the idea of a little old
robot reading just a little old classic
uh it's incredible i dig it i love your
character i love the spirit behind this
render
super widescreen like ridiculous
widescreen on this one
i don't even know what format that is
but it's crazy
i dig your dig your background to dig
your trees looking good
um i don't know if those are photo scans
or what but super solid
i think the only thing you can work on
is the service imperfections on your guy
they're a little intense
and they're a little too uniform maybe
you can
use some noise
to break it up a little bit
but your your idea
and the way you executed it got you in
to the challenge winners
this week slash this month
so congratulations to you noah
matos matos
very good stuff and finally we have
the man the myth the legend
visual
himself
with this
terrifying render can you imagine being
that woman
heck no
the render quality is ridiculous the
lighting's ridiculous the lighting tells
the story it shines light on your
subject but just in the shadows you see
the woman getting pulled away from her
newborn baby
that's probably not a newborn that's
probably a
two or three months who knows but
god this is terrifying super dark
um
visual this is amazing stuff
you got the challenge winner roll this
week but since you're a mod you gave it
away
to someone in the honorable mentions
which i'm getting into
right now starting with our boy
ronan
who is also a moderator so no you're not
getting the challenge the challenge went
a roll because he'd be passing it off as
well
i love this
so cool dude
like to come across this would be
terrifying i love the scene you set up i
love your use of depth of field
it really shows like how large this
thing is
dude this is this thing's massive it
might as well be an elephant and you
have a hunter and his kid
holding them back from this thing you
got the arm out
i love this it's so good
so freaking good congrats throwing an
honorable mention just wanted to shout
you out next up we got peter peter m
this is a super solid little render
this one made me smile
he's like okay
this little guy right here
not feeling it not feeling it
this is the spot i'm a chilling it
reminds me of my cat
that's great peter m good stuff
very good stuff next up we have jc
kb
i love it here i love it
childhood vibes very uh colorful vibrant
and fun
except for the fact the robot in the
back is trying to freaking slingshot a
bird
that's not chill
but i love your render
your quality is great
i dig your uh composition
overall i dig your story
that's why i chose this
i just needed to shout it out i like the
vibes here good stuff
next up we have yah cg mod who has been
lurkin
in the discord for a very long time and
you finally have unearthed yourself
to bust out this render right here i
love it i love the design of your robot
of course your lighting your composition
it's spot-on it's good to have you back
yaw cgmod i hope things are going all
right with you
and i hope that you have time and are
able to take a break and
make a little bit of a
infinite journey submission i can't wait
to see what you do i believe you were in
the top 100
uh
last time
i can't remember but you put out great
stuff
i look forward to seeing more of it
next up we got jones lab
honorable mention for jones lab bringing
technology and nature together in one
single render this is cool this is very
very cool you got some creepy dark robe
dudes
either i i don't know if the dude in
here
is like
is it unbeknownst to him
that
he's being watched by some creepy robe
dudes or is he like did he take off the
robe and was like time to step up
and went into this test chamber
i don't know if they would have cool
jackets
hanging out in creepy robe town
so i'm assuming it's someone who doesn't
know what's going on which is really
creepy
had to shout it out good stuff
next up we got i am creative
the reason i chose this is because the
idea
i love this idea you're using technology
to access nature
that is super cool
i dig it i really really dig it and like
with that comes a whole bunch of
different opinions on is that a good
thing is that a bad thing
who knows
it leaves it open-ended it's not saying
one thing or another it's just showing
that you can do this
and it and it brings out like
many different reactions and people like
oh that's cool or like oh why don't you
just go out in nature or also like oh
man that's the only way i can experience
nature it's very peaceful
so i love that um i am creative keep it
up good idea
uh three more we got carter next just
wanted to shout you out how could you
not love this this came very close to
winning i love the idea i love the
way you you shot this i love the way you
built this and lit this
absolutely incredible
i also love the fact that you have like
a really dark
kind of over-the-shoulder blurry
foreground object on the left i don't
know what it is it might be the robot's
face
but
it looks cool if it was if it wasn't
there it would be okay but the fact that
it's there i love it
i think this is incredible so congrats
to you
carter um and we got jack the hack next
just want to give you a shout out man
this one came darn close to winning as
well i must say because your render
quality is spot-on
um
i'm trying to figure out exactly what's
going on that's the one thing i'm trying
to figure out is like you have some sort
of reading and you're reading like i'm a
big mushroom you're reading the
electricity in a big mushroom i guess
um
i dig your colors i like the blue i like
the different emissions you use for the
lightning and stuff
on
i don't know are those splines or like
hair
it's really cool i dig it a lot
you put a lot of work into the scene and
i can tell
it came very very very close this week
um so
jack i just want to give you a shout out
man it's looking really cool and finally
we got folio
with this beautiful render
again you came darn close to winning you
came so close to winning that visual
decided to pass on his uh challenge
winner role to you
for this week's uh challenge slash month
because again we're just doing infinite
journeys this month so folio congrats
man you got that one from visual i dig
this a lot it came very close
in my mind as well um
you got nature benefiting from
technology i guess
in this way right you got the fox taking
cover under a little wing
find a nice little nest for itself
staying away from the heat
um
but yeah brutal it's a brutal brutal
combination there
freaking crazy
but yeah guys congratulations to the
weekly winners
technology meets nature very good stuff
you guys got full access to the discord
server uh for the remainder of february
or until we do another weekly challenge
which will probably be in march to be
honest with y'all
um so keep it up keep it up no doubt
we have
a couple
comments to say hello to
we got nexib yo thank you for the super
chat much appreciated paynes to see
another awesome challenge pop up and i
have arm and joint issues i will still
try but maybe model less and acquire
some models
ah
dang okay arm and joint issues man i'm
sorry to hear that definitely sorry to
hear that dude um
hopefully you're seeing a physical
therapist and and getting some workouts
that you can do to to get that
working out now i don't know if you use
a mouse all the time i will say i don't
know where these arm and joint issues
are coming from um for me personally i i
like to stay away from a mouse a
traditional mouse
so you'll see me on this pen tablet all
the time and i use this to keep
basically when you're when you're using
a mouse
right
you have your two forearm bones that are
running parallel but when you do a mouse
like this they're twisting
like this and that's no good
so that's when you use the pen
and you basically take your bones from
here and you open them up back to a
natural
natural state
right so that's why i love using
the wacom tablet
but man um
shoot
i hope you feel better take care of
yourself
and um yeah dude download some models
quick soul they got everything they
literally have like everything they just
got trees now that's amazing
so i hope to see you do something cool
just maybe maybe a little something
small
just don't hurt yourself
certainly don't hurt yourself i
appreciate the super chat though thank
you thank you thank you very much
that's awesome
all right
that's the super chats y'all are killing
it thank you guys so much for for
joining me still we got still got 755
people up in this chat
um i'm gonna take a very small break and
just take a minute break
um and then i'll come back i might work
on my blackout for another five minutes
or so and i'll chill with you guys so
brb
keep working on your stuff i'll see you
in a second
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what's up y'all
all right
i'm gonna go for probably another five
minutes or so ten minutes
working my block out just a little bit
more
oh
um are you guys digging the music we got
some music this time first time we ever
had music during the stream you guys
like it or do you prefer to have your
own just play your own music
see you
later
what's up
present
digital ape chilling what's going on
you just finished your block out barack
you finished your block out if you send
it to me on discord i will show it if
you can send it in the next two minutes
4k productions shout outs man thank you
for the super chat
good stuff good stuff visual likes the
music heck yeah y'all like the music
it's mad relaxing it's so relaxing it
just
just makes me want to break something
heck yeah
oh nice okay so you can still listen to
your own soundtrack and join the stream
and like oh it's it's the music's low
enough that you can put on your own i
like that heck yeah hades man that game
is incredible
no i did not model the pilot that is a
miximo download
dejohn
dejean maybe i'm saying that right um
you haven't started yours yet don't
worry dude all good you still have 23
days present i appreciate the kind words
thanks man
vfx works finish your block out that's
what's up send it to me on discord i
might show it in the next two minutes
heck yeah just finished your concept
paint nate that's cool stuff
you send it to me on the discord i might
show it off
votremir is ready for the next challenge
this is the challenge you ready for the
next one
that's crazy
anish you're asking for me to not choose
the winners before i stream i gotta
choose the winners before i stream i
gotta make sure that those winners are
eligible to claim those prizes before i
stream so i gotta make sure that those
winners are chosen before the stream
but no doubt i'll still reveal the top
100 and the five winners
in first week of march first week of
march the live stream
oh wow okay okay
we got some block outs here this one's
from
let me see
from er montezaro
working on your scene little robo
situation
giant tentacle in the background whoa
i love it
keep it up keep it up
keep working on it i dig it
dig it very much
there's devon's block out
all right so is the back of a
boat this is a boat i would assume
you're in the water
nice
nice nice
so
devon a couple things i would say is
like what other pieces of detail are you
going to see along this little boat
is there another boat out here
that broke off and is trying to get into
this cove
because there's some treasure up in this
thing you know
some things to think about
also
you want to keep that window frame right
so how are you going to block the sides
to keep that window center framed
right
are you going to have anything to guide
the
the eye to the middle of your render
keep that in mind as well
[Music]
oh sick
all right we got from malfunction
induced nate that is this dude's name
on discord check this out though
super cool
some sort of factory robo-factory
situation
i like it a lot
really cool um concept block out here
you did
with photoshop or something doesn't
really matter
painted it out i like that you did that
very very cool
oh wow okay so this one's from uh
from koto clothes
this is pretty intense
this is quite the scene here it's a
helicopter rescue lost your buddy kind
of thing
i dig it
very very scary definitely wouldn't want
to be in this person's situation but
you're doing a good job
zeus creates
that's cool
dang i love this feeling man i love this
style
so much
hopefully them chains will be dangling
as this thing moves i don't know if it's
a train or whatnot but
that's gonna be sick
zeus creates good stuff good stuff
oh wow
so this is actually an underwater scene
it looks like
let's see if i can play the animation
[Music]
oh it's a full-on underwater like
oh that's gonna be crazy very
interesting
can't wait to see how you make this a
thing and what you turn this into that's
gonna be sweet salty nugget
that's gonna be fun
see who else we got
pickle
so this one i'd really try and get your
window up a little higher and match the
the position of the original window
this one's a little low
just keep that in mind
um you want to
get closer to the original
template
window in terms of position
but
i love your fancy uh train setup you got
going i think that's gonna be sweet
pickle good times
3d gala
all right let's test this one out let's
see what you got going
oh my god
attack on titan
dude that's so cool
this dude's about to commit suicide and
this was this dude
these okay these are world german world
war ii
outfits they look kind of like that
is this dude playing cards and this
dude's about to kill himself
brutal brutal it's the last last escape
but i guess he's not gonna escape
that's cool man
super cool super super cool i love it i
love that you took that window and you
like
you're still having the focus here on
the center
that's awesome
can't wait to see your connector down
here
that's gonna look super cool your
dynamics are gonna look cool
awesome awesome awesome
um braebin
we got a little
a little sneak peek a little work in
progress here this is looking cool
sci-fi train
sci-fi city
you got ads on the back of the seat
i love it good stuff man keep it up keep
it up
oh okay sketchy salamander you have a
centrifuge
um zero gravity training machine
this is a wonderful idea
dude absolutely wonderful idea
i can't wait to see how this turns out i
love me some g-forces so it'll be super
cool to see that
yes
yes yes yes
what else do we got i'll do a couple
more here
i love this okay
tom the tank engine you got a little
concept that you drew out
i love it very very much man
crushing it
and this is where you're at right now
cool
yeah i dig it i think you're gonna do it
out of cardboard and like
kids crayon kind of style
i love it
tom the tank engine can't wait to see
what you do there
oh bouncy hippo
nice little steampunk work in progress
it almost looks like a stop-motion or
claymation or something like that
that's gonna be sweet
i'm down for this
this train ride
bouncy hippo good stuff
all right and i think that
is about
it um baldassor let's check that out
real quick
sleepy soldier hopefully sleepy soldier
cool little reveal of the background
there i like it
oh and you get some steam outside the
window too
that's cool
down keep it up that looks good baldasor
and i think that's it for now y'all
that is it for now
i appreciate you sending in your works
in progress showing the community
getting them excited for all this stuff
um
i think that's that's just about it
that's about it
thank you all so much for hanging out
with me
for chilling
um
where are you where are y'all at let me
get that chat back
it's somewhere anyway
good times y'all
thank you so much
uh i'll see you here next week i will be
here next week um
doing the same old deal hopefully i'll
be a little further along the way
uh in my submissions
so much appreciated you all thank you
thank you so much
um thank you to sotomonte holding it
down helping me stream streaming
producing killing it
and to all y'all keep up the great work
i can't wait to see what we do
keep sending me your works in progress
i'll show some more on the stream next
week
hopefully have a little bit more
progress done with mine i would love to
be into like the kind of fine tuning not
fine tuning but like
most of
the modeling and geometry is is in place
that's where i'd like to be next week so
hold me to it all right that's what i'ma
do
um but until then love y'all thank you
so much hop on the discord keep up the
good work and share all that love with
the community keep them excited and
until next time
i'll catch y'all next week
peace out
[Music]
two
[Music]
you